the first topic that we will be
discussing is entitled significance and
ambivalence of faiths what do we mean by
significance in the bivens well
significance suggests exploration of the
topic why is it that faiths matter in
today's world what makes them such
weighty topic that we need to engage
them in contemporary setting an
ambivalence we want to look at kind of
two sidedness both positive and negative
aspects of faith and also how particular
acts from a particular vantage point
even within the signified may look
differently the case studies we will
explore is terrorist attack of 911 and
there we see very clearly ambiguity of
religion religion displayed on the one
hand religion was a motivating force one
but nonetheless important motivating
force for these terrorist attacks at the
same time these terrorist attacks were
condemned from the same religion that
motivated those as well as from other
religions and we want to explore what is
it it makes on the one hand religion
legitimized violence on the other hand
call it into question the second case we
will be studying is Jubilee 2000
coalition to cancel third-world debt the
significant movement I think displays
very in very interesting ways how faith
can take people outside of themselves
transcend the boundaries of
self-interest and engage with people
across the borders engage in the lib
with poverty-stricken people around the
world and here to faith then functions
as a motivating force a positive force
in globalization processes we want to
examine these and get clarity on how and
why faith functions is the positive and
how and why in functions in a negative
way